تعال على
الرغم من أن Apple و Samsung تسرعان
في إخبارك أن iPhone 7 و
galaxy s7 مقاومان للماء وليسان مقاومان
للماء ، فقد قررنا دفعهما إلى
الحد
الأقصى ، حيث حصل iPhone على تصنيف IP67 و
IP68 من Samsung أفضل قليلاً مما يعني أن
كلا الهاتفين يمكنه  يدوم حوالي 30 دقيقة
تحت الماء ، لكن يمكن لجهاز iPhone أن
يتخطى مسافة ثلاثة أقدام فقط تحت الماء
بينما يمكن أن يصل سمك السامسون إلى ما يقرب من خمسة أقدام ،
لكن شركة Apple تقول إنه لا يجب أن تأخذ
هواتفهم في المحيط أثناء الاستحمام أو أن
حمام السباحة الذي يوجد
بهاتفان بهما بعض من  أفضل
الكاميرات التي صنعتها هذه الشركات على الإطلاق
، وعلى الرغم من أنهم قد لا يوصون بها
للتصوير تحت الماء ، إلا أننا لا نستطيع
مقاومة جعل هذه الهواتف
مقاومة للماء ، وهو أمر لا بد منه الآن للحفاظ
على قدرتها التنافسية ، ولكنها في الواقع قد
تكون سيئة للأعمال كلما طال عمر هذه
الهواتف  كلما قلنا من الحاجة إلى الترقية
وسيساعد ذلك في المساهمة في
بعض الانخفاضات التي شهدناها في
مبيعات الهواتف الذكية ، حسنًا ،
فكيف كان أداء الهواتف في
نهاية السباحة  بدأ galaxy s7 في
مواجهة بعض المشكلات ، حيث توقفت الأزرار والكاميرات
عن العمل ،
وبعد ذلك تلقينا رسالة خطأ عندما
حاولنا
شحنه وبدأ التكثيف ببطء في الظهور في
الكاميرات ، وأصبح الهاتف غير قابل للاستخدام بشكل أساسي
الآن ، ولا يزال iPhone من ناحية أخرى يعمل
بقوة.  تختلف
ولكن حذر من أن تحصل على سوائل في
هاتفك ، فإن الضمانات لا تزال لا تغطي
الأضرار الناجمة عن المياه